westminster leader for the snp is with
us now mr blackford good morning you've
got a smile on your face this morning
well look at the end of the day i don't
think there's much to be happy about i
think our politics is in crisis we've
got a situation as of now
10 members stop you one second will
quince who was on the programme on
monday defending the prime minister has
just quit he is an education minister
children's minister he has just quit we
were speculating yesterday whether that
would happen he sat exactly where you
are with great sadness uh and regret he
says uh that he has decided to leave
this government he sat there and he did
defend the prime minister he said that
he was told by number ten um one thing
and then several three hours later um
they said something else sorry i
interrupted you no i feel for him or
anyone that's gone out to defend the
indefensible when they've been lied to
let's be clear about that it's 11 tory
mps that have now gone in the last 24
hours this is a crisis there's one man
that now needs to accept that he is the
problem that he's lost the trust of the
people of these islands he's lost the
trust of the house of commons and indeed
a vast number of his mps and he now
needs to
realize that he has to go we've got
prime minister's questions today there's
lots of things we can be talking about
we need to be talking about the cost of
living crisis the war in ukraine
but we won't be because we'll be
speaking about boris johnson he's now a
block
on us in the house of commons doing the
job that we need to do and for the good
of everybody
boris johnson has to go you don't hold
back though do you in the house of
commons you're not without guilt when it
comes to giving him a good kicking
during prime minister's quest well i've
got a voice at prime minister's
questions and i've got a responsibility
to represent my constituents in my party
but i have to say i'm ashamed as to
where we are i'm ashamed about the
standards in public life about someone
that's lied to the house of commons
that's breached the trust it was put in
them that over the whole party gate
thing the only prime minister
in office that's been found to have
broken his own laws he simply shouldn't
be here and we stumble on from crisis to
crisis there has to be an end to this we
need to be able to go on and tackle the
immense challenges that we that we have
and this man simply is going to have to
be i suspect
drag kicking and screaming out of office
whether that's done by tory mps because
they change their own rules or whether
in the end it's by the privileges
committee doing their job this prime
minister will be gone
for the sake of any everyone and for his
own dignity and self-respect
he needs to realize that this is over
you uh respect nadim zahaway i'm
guessing he's a man that's very popular
in the house of commons chamber he says
the prime minister has integrity well i
have to say i'm really disappointed that
nazim has said that i don't think there
are many people that can suggest that
the prime minister has integrity he
doesn't there's a
charge he as long as you're armed in
terms of the indiscretions of this prime
minister and when you have a prime
minister that has repeatedly lied he
doesn't seem to know the difference
between
truth and lying it's not defendable and
i'm sorry that
nazim has said what he has this morning
because it's clearly patently not the
case it's a man that has no integrity as
the man has no shame um on your view on
the fact that sadie javid and rishi
sunak have decided to step away well
i'll thank them for what they did
yesterday um we know about the character
of the prime minister this should have
happened some time ago but my message to
conservative mps do your job whether
it's rishi uh whether sad you the rest
of them now have to step up to the plate
let's bring this to an end let's not
continue the pain
any longer and let's make sure that we
press the reset button and that we can
rebuild trust and policy i want scotland
to go in a different direction but i
want to make sure that we can actually
do the job that we need to do while
we're in westminster and that means
tackling the crisis that we face you
know we're going to go into the winter
very soon the cost of living crisis is
very much with us we need to make sure
we're dealing with inflation let's deal
with the fundamentals and we can only do
that when we lance the boil that's there
when this prime minister has gone from
office and if there's a snap election
will you still see that as the snp
as a referendum on whether there should
be another independence referendum you
know our first minister spoke last week
about the road map that we have trying
to make sure that we can deliver on the
mandate that we have for an independence
referendum but let me say that i will
relish an election for us to put the
case for scotland to be an independent
country we have a road map that's in
place i want to make sure that we remove
boris johnson but in the end of the day
it's westminster it's brexit that's
causing us so much damage and let's not
forget that this week of all weeks that
the labour leader has come out and said
there's no one going back into europe
there's no going back into the single
market the customs union scotland has
its own way forward which is an
independent country back into europe and
that's what we will do but i certainly
know
only if the westminster parliament
allows you to well i think you know at
the end of the day this is about
democracy and westminster should respect
that the snp and our partners in the
greens that there's an independence
mandate in the scottish parliament
people of scotland have got the right to
have a say in their future and
westminster should respect that one way
or the other an independence referendum
will happen
i want to put that case as to why we can
deliver that greener and that more
prosperous scotland back in the european
union that will happen and the sooner
that happens the better for everybody
but my message to westminster is come
and meet with us let's agree how we can
have an independence referendum like we
did in 2014 based on the edinburgh
agreement let's respect democracy and
let's respect the rights of people of
scotland
election or any election but
particularly if it's uh it's quite soon
would you see that as a referendum on an
independence referendum well what we've
said first and foremost is that we want
to take this to the supreme court let's
do that and we said of course um what we
have let's assume that we can win that
we have a referendum if we don't then of
course we will look at our tactics for
an independence referendum using a
general election but the sequence of
that will be going to the supreme court
first if there's an election before that
of course we'll we'll think long and
hard about how we fight that election
but it will be about scotland's right to
have a referendum and to be an
independent okay could we see ourselves
in a position where we've got a perfect
storm in westminster this um by the end
of this week prime minister has to go
the leader of the opposition has to go
because of what's happened with um
durham and uh drinking a beer and you're
in quite a bit tricky uh situation as
well at the moment aren't you i'm
determined to make sure that i lead the
snp group at westminster and i'm ready
to stand shoulder-to-shoulder with
colleagues in the scottish government to
fight the independence referendum of
course all of us have faced issues in
terms of what has happened a bad
behavior at westminster i'm determined
to make sure that we lead by example i'm
reviewing uh our disciplinary code i
want to make sure that staff whether
it's in the snp or elsewhere in
westminster can feel safe yeah but um
did you know about the allegation and
did you try to protect him no and at no
time at all and you know i was involved
with a number of others in making sure
that we set up the icgs scheme a way
back in 2018 i think we need to reflect
on where we are we need to make sure
that we are protecting everyone that
works in the house of commons i'm
determined that we do that
that we take our responsibility
seriously i'm sorry for anyone that's
faced any bullying any harassment any
sexual misconduct and we need to make
sure that staff are always uh supported
that is the obligation that we have and
i'm absolutely crystal clear that we
must do that and i'll take my
responsibilities in the snp to make sure
that what do you say to people who make
the comparison between
this situation and what the prime
minister was trying to do with chris
printscher
look at the end of the day it's vastly
different we had a
process that happened to take place
through the icgs i've upheld the
decisions that took place patrick grady
was suspended he's no longer an snp mp
it's important that people face
consequences for their actions and i'm
determined to make sure that those that
have faced
bullying sexual harassment that they get
justice and you didn't try just to find
one i know i said that was fine but this
is definitely the final point um you
didn't try to stop people making that um
situation public no absolutely not at
all um i mean if any anybody ever comes
to me i will discharge my obligations
and i'll make sure that anybody and
everybody are signposted to the
opportunities that there are for them to
take complaints forward that's the right
thing to do and that's what i've always
done good to talk to you as always mr
blackfoot thanks for taking the time to
join us on the program